she's just like you need to stop doing
that and then I started to change the
subject of how is school going boys and
my sons tell me well we didn't have
school today technically I'm like well I
was on he said well there was like a
school shooting drill I never heard of
this you know what this is
they have drills that they make kids do
uh where they practice what to do if
somebody comes to shoot up their school
I've never heard that before I was like
what the [__]
then I had to tell my sons the truth I
didn't want to tell them this [__] son
son listen to me
[__] that drill
somebody comes to your school and wants
to shoot it up I'm just going to be
honest with you
you're probably gonna get shot [__] I'm
just being real
you got a famous dad I talk a lot of
[__] they gonna be gunning for you
little buddy
just stay low and running a zigzag
pattern and don't try to save anybody
son do you understand me
[Applause]
if you're a parent this [__] is
terrifying this [__] is real scary all
the parents is looking at each other
crazy
because we know as parents that one of
us is raising the shooter
just don't know which one of us it is
all we know for sure
is that if you're a white parent the
chances that it's you
exponentially higher than the rest of us
it's [__] crazy you know I hated
school too it never occurred to me
kill everybody in school
it's [__] crazy
just do what I did [__] try some things
have you skipped school [__] skip
school
take a walk and meet some other kids
[__] school you know what I said
that's all I said first of all I'll tell
you right now what I said uh and I will
tell you that this was not a joke it's a
true story
and I just happened to tell her all
right what happened was I went to a
gallery party all right I don't know who
in here has ever been Rich before but
these are very nice parties
uh you know wine and cheese and baller
conversation
and there was a few eccentric types one
of which was a very wealthy man that
happened to be wearing a dress I don't
know what you call Manly this is a
[__] or drag queen perhaps whatever it
was it's definitely a man
and this man was definitely on drugs I
don't know what kind of drugs he's on
but I knew he had too much he didn't
look good it's like this he's like ah he
looks sick and all his friends were
standing around him concerned trying to
revive them I don't know whether it
looked like some kind of gay CPR those
Fanning and [__]
foreign
my own business but I got curious I was
like
and I went over there all I said I said
excuse me gentlemen gentlemen is he okay
and then they looked at me like I was
evil
she is fine
you said word oh
I'm sorry I didn't know this is what we
were doing
um
foreign
here's my thing
I would support anybody's right to be
whoever they feel like they are inside
I'm your ally in that
however
my question is
to what degree do I have to participate
in your self-image
is it fair to have to change my whole
pronoun game up for this [__]
that didn't make sense
seriously
if I put on an Argyle Sweater and I'm
like hey everybody I feel like a white
guy in the sweater and I want some
goddamn respect in a bank loan it's not
gonna work
give a [__] how I feel why does that
give a [__] how you feel [__] is a
pronoun
but there was no time for philosophical
debate this was an emergency situation
I said fine sorry guys I was just
worried because
she looks terrible
she just fell off the bench
appears that her dick is popping out of
her dress
you mind if I call an ambulance champ
I'd rather not be at a party where
[__] ODS there's too many questions to
answer
[Applause]
we blacks we look at the gay community
we go God damn it look how well that
movement is going
look how well you are doing
and we've been trapped in this
predicament for hundreds of years how
the [__] are you making that kind of
progress
I can't help but feel like
if slaves have baby oil and booty shorts
we might have been
[Applause]
if Martin Luther King was like I want
everybody to get a bone and floats
get your bodies good and shiny
foreign
[Music]
guys you be at a club but all right he's
kicking with your boys and and a girl
walks by and a man she looks good she
looks good not good in that classical
way
I mean you know I'm talking good like
she got half her ass hanging out her
skirt
her titties are all mashed together
popping out the top of her turtleneck
and [__]
[Applause]
and he was your buddies right he was
your buddies you got a couple drinks in
you and your secret is you might try to
talk to it this might not come out right
now I don't know what you're saying damn
look at them titties
[Applause]
wait a minute
just because I'm dressed this way
does not
make me a [__]
[Applause]
which is true
gentlemen that is true just because they
dress a certain way doesn't mean they
are a certain way don't ever forget it
but ladies you must understand that that
is [__] confusing
his hands
now that would be like me Dave Chappelle
the comedian walking around the streets
in a cop uniform
somebody might run up on me oh thank God
officer help us come on they're over
here help us
oh
just because I'm dressed this way
does not make me a police officer
I was like all right lady bye
fine you are not a [__]
but you are wearing a horse uniform I'll
tell you that [__]
how old is 15 really
oh that's a good question that's a good
question
I'm not saying that a person is as smart
as they're going to be at 15. that's not
what I'm saying man but I am saying
15 to me
it's old enough to decide
whether or not you want to be pissed on
I mean that's me if you can't make a
decision like that by the time you're 15
then just give up [__] because
life is way harder than that
I make tougher decisions all the time if
you don't want to get pissed I won't
just get the [__] out of the way it's
not even a decision if I stop peeing on
the front row they're not gonna have to
calculate and think how do I feel about
this am I okay with it they just move
you can do that at 15. I could have I've
been 15. when I was 15. I was doing
stand-up and night clubs I smoked Reef
from time to time friends were selling
crack I was trying to finger [__] people
I knew what was happening around me
to some degree
getting pissed on was the least of my
worries at 15. trust me
foreign
but it keeps coming up it's a lot of
confusion around that age anytime 15
comes up people freak out like when that
girl Elizabeth Smart got kidnapped
right remember in Utah last year's 15
year old girl Elizabeth small was
kidnapped and then they finally found
her and the whole country was relieved
and I was the only one saying damn she
wasn't that smart after all
not cause she got kidnapped that could
happen to anybody I'm not knocking her
for that I'm just saying if you're
kidnap me when I was 15
gotta take me further than eight miles
away from my house man God damn
you can't hold me prison around [__] I
recognize I'll break away I'll break
away [__] off me [__] that's my bus
stop I know I'm at I'm going home
[Applause]